We know that acceleration is somehow special,
but how is acceleration special?
Let's think of a cart, and we want to accelerate this cart.
Accelerating it would make us happy.
If we want to design an experiment to test what factors affect acceleration--let's think.
When I push this cart what factors will control at what rate it accelerates?
Does it matter how hard I push?
Does it matter what material the cart is made of?
Does the mass of the cart matter?
Will a heavier cart maybe accelerate at a different rate?
Does the color of the cart matter?
Will a red paint job make the cart accelerate faster?
To get you thinking about this, I want you to choose all that you think apply.
When you see the answer, you maybe surprised
at whether or not it matches with your intuition.